[Music]
Rainbow six siege is still a young
eSport but for most of its life so far
it seems like it would never be freed
from the iron grip of one absurdly
dominant roster it seemed like no
challenger would ever be able to throw
the tyrant that was g2 but in Raleigh
that all changed but before we get into
that we want to tell you guys about the
softs Rainbow six siege us nationals
2019 for six siege action from the best
players in na you've got a tune into the
US Nationals you can find out more info
on movie soft seas channels which will
link in the description below Zhi Zhu's
era was intended by one of the many
teams who've been trying to take their
throne for years they fell to the
greatest dark horse in siege history a
ragtag band of Russians who clawed their
way up from challenger league all the
way to pro Lee
they fell to team Empire gentlemen one
more time for your champions
empire
what started as the CIS is first real
hope of even having a recognizable siege
roster has become the game's newest
terror and they got to the top faster
than any team ever has before
sure Eastern Europeans are obsessed with
Counter Strike but it took them a long
time to get interested in Rainbow six
siege before Empire only one CAS roster
had ever made it to pro league they were
there for exactly one season and they
finished dead last
it's no good beats infamous desert it's
just like that all said and done
most wanted fall and playing dancing
five rounds to one seal out the series
so how did Empire managed to flip the
script well the rest of the world first
heard of the Russian roster we know in
fear today in late 2017 back then the
initial core of joystick Shepherd and
shockwave joined forces on an org called
room factor they plowed their way
through every regional tournament they
attended 1 year 2 season 3 of the
European Challenger League and in
February 18 qualified for the 6
Invitational will win the round and make
it 5 to 3 that just completely fell at
the end amazingly played by room factory
we will see them in Montreal
unfortunately it turned out that they
weren't quite ready to compete
internationally we was at the
invitational 2018 we was like room
factory it was our first big tournament
and we we really played bed there
this is room factory just falling apart
yes but one shot will finish it off
might freak we'll go back and have one
more chance at making the Invitational a
pack is here Mindfreak eliminating room
factory 2 2 1
still they continued to dominate
domestically they added two new names in
Karjakin and Scyther and nearly qualify
for the six major in Paris by July they
de proven that they were the CIS is
first real seed roster that's when they
became Empire we had a lot of boot camps
like a really long time boot camp so we
worked hard on that and the may think is
the Willing we were willing to be the
best there run through smaller
tournaments was just the beginning they
were working their way up through the
European sieve scene starting with CCS
season
than the ESL Euro Cup 2018 and then
winning season eight of challenge early
qualifying themselves the prolene raisin
2-1 but too much for him to deal with
and Shepherd will land the last kill
Bootsie will go down ladies and
gentlemen Empire have taken it
congratulations they make it into Pro
League and we'll see them in just a few
weeks for the start of season nine
it was around this time that people
started to wonder what made this Russian
darkhorse so damn good well for starters
there was the fact that they were forced
to cut their teeth in a Europe the
single most competitive scene in all of
C you have really good the competitive
players here in Europe and it's really
good and then we improve a lot through
only one year we need only one year to
improve like like this yeah I think it
is because we are in Europe man there's
joy stack you guys say yeah juristic t30
blah blah blah he's not cheating he's
[ __ ] cyborg made by Soviet Union's
for they wanted to build up a perfect
soldier
but then Soviet Soviet Union crashed and
they had no use for a subsequent super
killer agent so they decided because
Russian suck in eastward we need to have
at least one good player and they boot
joystick the cyber play rainbow succeeds
and now he's the best in addition to
being Empires top Fragger this semi-pro
csgo player turns each god had an
ability to absolutely annihilate his
opponents but not in the way you might
expect that's the thing we had a
discussion our team almost every event
but like he doesn't look amazing on
paper he doesn't have like you know
shroud aim he doesn't have any of that
but he's like the most performing player
of recent times basically that he's the
new Kento of anything with a new nest as
people call it see joystick isn't your
typical superstar he doesn't have
inhuman mechanics or galaxy brain game
sense he just has this ability to
dumster people and the messiest and most
haphazard way as possible
joystick mentioned it before but yeah
like fragging play yeah so if there's
one player to take a look at on team
empire its joystick now it's a retake
for the two roamers joystick will not
what joy
dick turns on uno absolute destruction
joystick somehow has made himself
upstairs again how do you how do you
help you get back upstairs joystick
Bootsy will take outside there and the
phone call you know how did you not hear
it this could be a free kill for
joystick and it will be after Wilkie
takes down car Zeca in the site though
these kills from joystick from above are
going to be so much more important the
diffuse plank going down and joystick
will see it and he will take down the
thermite boots the eliminated and that
puts it into a two-on-two Chuck and the
site will lose to Wilkie but there's no
time look at joint sync again are you
what is going on
Empire win the round off the back of
joystick and choice to cologne at first
people thought joystick was the biggest
reason why Empire was so good that their
wins revolved around their ability to
enable this one explosive Fragger no
one's watching the hash that's exactly
was punishing him he's gonna pick up two
he's going for great Eddy Get Set
joystick the first round 14 Empire but
the stronger that Empire got the more
apparent it became that that was not the
case I don't want to say this as like an
insult but one thing I want to say is he
is the most overrated player on Empire
and I say this because everyone talks
about him as if he is the best player on
Empire and like I always say this like
all the pros say that's even in the pro
area when we watch our games cuz we
always say that he's overrated because
he gets so much hype and then we always
also start to say who we think the best
player on the team is and the funny
thing is every time it's all 5 or
listing
and then we go and realist recyclers
right but it really all like all aren't
saying like knowing like literally every
single one of them every one of our team
can step up in the important moment and
do the craziest things that people
wouldn't even expect we understand each
other 100% cuz we are friends and life
Russian eSports teams in dozens of games
are famous for a specific brand of a
hyper aggressive play but Empire took
that sort of all in the Vai play style
and polished it into an organized chaos
there is nothing special in our game
style we're just trying to work on every
mistake we see on the screams like and
everything's dis Russians words or
divide the wide that gives us a lot of
like mental boost so yeah just in our
opinion 70% of our success it's just the
moral thing and come the New Year Empire
entered the six Invitational 2019
serious contenders and after sailing
through the group stage and two thirds
of the bracket they made it to the grand
final where they were faced with their
toughest opponent yet the greatest C's
roster of all time g2 esports MS Madrid
had predicted like a month ago Empire
did you finally like there's no way
empire first you know there's a new team
that just made Pro League and somehow
someway they've made all its defined a
lot with a pretty hot bracket like
they've been
well here we have it our very final
matchup of the six Invitational a day
that we have waited for for a long long
time
will we see a team playing in the
biggest match of their lives
team Empire crowned new world champions
or one of the most dominant and best
teams that we've ever seen play this
game defend their title and raise that
hammer for a second time boiler empire
lost
[Applause]
I think it it's it's really good that we
are we are we placed second we are
second place and in this tournament
because sometimes when you're winning
everything your team haven't got
motivation yeah I mean getting the
second place on the sixteen patient's
and losing to g2 was kind of a for us
down but not out
Empire made it their sole mission to the
Fiji to I think it's the most important
thing for us in all tournaments if you
if we see you too we need we know that
we need to be in them in finals and as
fate would have it GT started to slump
after their win at the invitational
meanwhile Empire completed one of the
most incredible comebacks and seeds
history defeating eg at the season nine
finals in Milan and earning their first
pro league championship to see if he can
save at the newest addition to this Evil
Geniuses roster it was brought on in
Herald as to somebody who could possibly
change the tide pressure from behind Gio
might not be aware that there's a Nevada
there we got Empire going to overtime
with eg three rounds unanswered and eg
will choke the lead they
and they'll need to think about that in
OT jump no need to walk up hitting a GU
- position giving away Empire with five
in a row will turn around and its empire
winning on time oh my god what a
performance from them and eg battered
and bruised will limp into map number
three with Empire a great position to
steal this matchup below the plant the
sound cue will give Tim the information
oh it takes what down as you crown a new
champion here in Milan Empire are your
season nine champions yeah it was a
really good comeback from us on the
Oregon I don't want to talk about club I
don't want to talk about bank then the
most important map for us it was already
done because we come back from six - I
think or six week they entered the six
major in Raleigh as the team to beat and
after clawing their way through the
quarter and semi finals they earned
their spot in the grand final where they
would face off against G - one more time
are they aware of this position no it
does not appear so and they have to
swing out but joystick as the cover he
fights - for his trouble and it's a
successful plan Empire everything in
their favor and it's all on Penghu
budding handle up here as the bottom
here comes the e you want you to take
bakery control it's gonna work great a
sooner takes down Dan Dan not knowing
he's exposed from behind but car Zeca
goes to the reef Ragan gets it though
there's Goga there from the front door -
also in a change in this round but it's
still Shepherd and cypher the two who
have been so clutch and the longer on in
sight they're looking to try and start
it well we got one they also catches
khoka
Spaniard will born HB downs and and
removes him from the equation Shepard
nestled up in the bomb site throws down
a toxic canister but there's no clutch
here g2 in the battle to the death now a
Shepherd pops up he sees one oh
absolutely crush Udo there's another
three Sheppard oh my god
Penghu now a toe on v3 is position given
away an empire looking to sit pretty
amidst the smoke as Penghu that Empire
will do something they had it done until
today which is take a map off of g2
they've taken two of them now and
they're gonna be on series point once we
come back for coastline to one team
empire by the time they played coastline
the map where g2 broke Empire back at
the invitational it was clear that this
time the Russians had what it took
empire well set up to counter this push
[Music]
choice to still not aware right but
here's one two kills three for Shepard
and the Empire Strikes Back
they will take the Rolly major and
disbelief how quickly it comes back
where it all began for Empire one of the
most memorable maps that we've ever seen
it was g2 prevailing over Empire earlier
this year on a coastline that didn't
ever want to end this time
Empire makes it quick and Empire will
win the Raleigh major championship
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen your winners of the
Raleigh major 2019 team
and that's how we got to where we are
today with Empire as the best team in
the world but this is the future look
like could we see Empire success convert
a region obsessed with counter-strike
into an unstoppable siege army I think
all Russian players are cybers well it's
certainly possible we've already seen a
second Russian team join pro league and
siege has received a blessing from one
of the CIS biggest csgo players so the
future of Russian siege it's pretty
bright yeah I think that the seizure go
for more popular in Russia
whatever happens Empire will always be
remembered as a team that brought the g2
era to an end and as far as empire are
concerned their work is far from over I
want to be remember like first team coup
could be g2 three or two or three times
in the road and the dynasty has fallen
for now but a new one Rises team empire
go and get that trophy that is yours
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
bring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Applause]